From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共电台发行。
Good morning.
早上好。
Morning.
We want to thank everyone for coming out this morning. We're excited because it's an election time.
我们想感谢今天早上到场的每一位。我们很兴奋，因为选举季到了。
Yeah!
耶！
This rally was just last month-- black elected officials from Chicago's West Side, two days before the primary election there. And what the rally was about, and what they were asking God to bless, was kind of unusual.
这场集会就在上个月举行——当时是初选前两天，芝加哥西区的黑人民选官员们齐聚一堂。这次集会的主题以及他们祈求上帝保佑的内容，有点不同寻常。
We pray now, Master, with this election time, that you bring clarity and understanding, and you bring victory back home to the ones that stand--
我们现在祈祷，主啊，在这个选举时刻，求你带来清晰和理解，并将胜利带回给那些坚守立场的人们——
Here's the victory that Reverend Randall is asking God to step in and help with. He wants God to help reelect Derrick Smith to the Illinois State House for the 10th district. Smith had been arrested just five days before this for accepting a $7,000 bribe. He'd originally asked for $5,000, and then he upped it to 7, and specified that it had to be in cash, according to an FBI informant. Allegedly Smith was getting the money as payment for writing a letter of support for a daycare center to get a government grant.
这就是兰德尔牧师请求上帝介入并帮忙争取的那场“胜利”。他想让上帝保佑德里克·史密斯再次当选伊利诺伊州众议院第10选区的议员。就在五天前，史密斯因为接受7000美元贿赂被捕。据联邦调查局线人称，他最初索要5000美元，后来加价到7000美元，并明确要求现金支付。据称，史密斯收钱是为了给一家日托中心写支持信，以获取政府拨款。
And this is the kind of case that when you hear the evidence, it doesn't seem to leave a lot of room for doubt. The exchange of money was recorded by the FBI. I read the 23-page FBI account of the case. Here's how it went down. The informant counts out the money-- "One, two, three, four, five-- damn, stuck together-- six, seven. Talk to you later." Smith says, "You don't want me to give you yours now? I'm going to get you your two, man." He had promised the informant $2,000-- that's on tape, also-- for bringing in the bribe.
当你听到证据时，这类案件似乎确实无可辩驳。这笔交易被联邦调查局录了下来。我阅读了这份23页的联邦调查局案件陈述。事情是这样的：线人清点着钱——“一、二、三、四、五——该死，粘在一起了——六、七。回头再聊。”史密斯说：“你不想让我现在就把你的那份给你吗？我会给你那两千块的，伙计。”他还向线人承诺了2000美元——这也有录音——作为介绍贿赂的报酬。
And, you may ask, how do certain Democratic officials view all of that evidence?
那么，你可能会问，一些民主党官员是如何看待所有这些证据的？
Derrick Smith has not been proven guilty. He is continuing to run for office. He's continuing--
德里克·史密斯尚未被证明有罪。他将继续竞选公职。他继续——
This is Cook County Commissioner Robert Steele.
这是库克县专员罗伯特·斯蒂尔。
So let's support Derrick until any time he is taken into the court system and found with anything that happened at that time. Derrick is an innocent candidate that's running for office. We're supporting an innocent candidate who's running for office. Let's support Derrick Smith! Let's support Derrick Smith!
所以，让我们在德里克真正进入司法系统并被判定有罪之前，一直支持他。德里克是一位清白的竞选者。我们正在支持一位竞选公职的清白候选人。让我们支持德里克·史密斯！让我们支持德里克·史密斯！
This is the official line of the day from the Democrats, and they came out in force-- five state reps, two state senators, four aldermen, various commissioners, the Illinois Secretary of State-- 20 of them are listed on the press release announcing this rally, headlined by somebody who is generally seen as a stand-up guy, well-liked, long-serving-- US Congressman Danny Davis.
这就是民主党人当天发出的官方口径，他们大举出动——五名州众议员、两名州参议员、四名市政委员、多名县专员、伊利诺伊州州务卿——宣布这次集会的新闻稿上列出了20个人，领头的是一位通常被视为正直、受欢迎、资历深厚的美国众议员——丹尼·戴维斯。
We know that our colleague is charged with criminal activity. But we also know that a charge is not a conviction.
我们知道我们的同事被指控有犯罪行为。但我们也知道，指控并不等于定罪。
That's right.
没错。
But we also know that there are circumstances that concerns us.
但我们也知道，有些情况让我们担忧。
And right here is where you get to the reason for the show of force by Democrats that day. The other candidate in this Democratic primary was Tom Swiss, the former director of the Cook County Republican Party. He entered the Democratic Party in the primary, according to an email that became public, because he thought it was going to be easy to win, calling the residents of the district, quote, "low-information voters." Danny Davis said that running a Republican in a Democratic primary was just subterfuge.
正是在这里，你明白了那天民主党人展示力量的原因。那次民主党初选中的另一位候选人是汤姆·斯威斯，他是库克县共和党前主席。根据一封公开的电子邮件，他参加民主党初选是因为他认为自己很容易获胜，他称该区的居民为“低信息选民”。丹尼·戴维斯说，在民主党初选中推举共和党人纯粹是诡计。
And we want to make sure that we don't elect a wolf in sheep's clothing.
我们想确保我们不会选出一只披着羊皮的狼。
That's right, that's right, that's right!
没错，没错，没错！
That we don't elect a wolf in sheep's clothing. Should, ultimately, the judicial process determine that Representative Smith cannot serve, then there would be the opportunity to make sure that a Democrat--
我们不会选出一只披着羊皮的狼。如果最终司法程序认定史密斯议员无法履职，那么届时还有机会确保一位民主党人——
That's right.
没错。
That a Democrat--
一位民主党人——
Right! Say that again!
对！再说一遍！
Is elected to that position. And that's why we're here this morning to support Derrick Smith, State Representative.
当选该职位。这就是我们今天早上在这里支持州众议员德里克·史密斯的原因。
Yeah! Derrick!
耶！德里克！
Derrick!
德里克！
No defeat! No defeat! Hold the seat! No defeat! Hold the seat! No defeat!
不能输！不能输！保住席位！不能输！保住席位！不能输！
I bring all this up because this week on our radio show, we have a bunch of stories in which people did something bad. Like, you know, endorsing somebody who just accepted a bribe on tape, just days before. And they knew it was bad. But it wasn't clear just how bad. After all, like Danny Davis, they had their reasons.
我之所以提起这一切，是因为本周我们的广播节目中有许多故事，讲述了人们做错事的情况。比如，支持一个几天前刚被录下收受贿赂的人。他们知道这是错的，但并不清楚到底有多错。毕竟，像丹尼·戴维斯那样，他们有自己的理由。
And in putting together today's show, we got talking amongst ourselves about how bad actually counts as bad. Basically, we were talking about levels of sin, and how to rate the different levels of sin. And you know, once you get into that game, you really need to turn to a professional.
在制作今天的节目时，我们谈论起“坏”到底是怎么定义的。基本上，我们在讨论罪的等级，以及如何衡量这些等级。你知道，一旦你进入这种博弈，你就真的需要求助于专业人士了。
I'm a Franciscan priest. Like a missionary priest. Father Augustino Torres.
我是一名方济各会修士，像是一名传教士修士。奥古斯丁·托雷斯神父。
Father Torres works with low-income people, especially young people, in Paterson, New Jersey, and very generously agreed to run us through the Catholic notions of serious and less serious sins, or-- the old Catholic terms for it-- mortal versus venial sins.
托雷斯神父在新泽西州帕特森为低收入群体工作，特别是年轻人，他非常慷慨地为我们讲解了天主教关于严重和较轻罪行的概念，或者用古老的天主教术语来说——大罪和小罪。
A venial sin-- "venial" comes from the Latin word "venia," which means, basically, to pardon. Pardonable. Something small. A mortal sin is something serious. The word "mortal" means something that kills. The three criteria for a mortal sin is, it's serious, I know it's serious, and with all my faculties, I do it anyway. It's serious, I know it's serious, and I do it anyway.
小罪——“venial”源自拉丁语“venia”，基本意思是宽恕。可宽恕的。一些微不足道的事。大罪则是严重的事。“mortal”这个词意味着会致死的东西。判定大罪有三个标准：事情很严重，我知道它很严重，并且尽管我有理智，我还是做了。事情很严重，我知道它很严重，我还是做了。
Mortal sins, unrepented for, send you to hell when you die. Getting right with God again to avoid that could take a long time and real personal change. Venial sins are so small that they're forgiven simply if you show up for mass. So under this scheme, a white lie-- obviously a venial sin. Murder or adultery, mortal sins. The Ten Commandments-- often, but not necessarily, mortal sins. Like, for example, the commandment on taking the Lord's name in vain.
大罪如果未经忏悔，死后会让你下地狱。为了避免这种情况而重获上帝的宽恕，可能需要很长时间和真正的个人改变。小罪则非常微小，只要参加弥撒就能得到宽恕。因此，根据这个机制，一个善意的谎言显然是小罪。谋杀或通奸则是大罪。十诫中的戒律通常——但不一定——是大罪。比如，关于妄称主名的那条戒律。
So John Doe is commuting back to New Jersey. He crosses two bridges, the Triborough and the George Washington Bridge, is in two hours of traffic, and then he gets home, finally, after driving home, and his son runs over him with his bike, on his foot, and he uses the Lord's name in vain. Is that a mortal sin? It's grave matter. It's serious. But if you were to bring me that situation, I would say, probably not.
假设约翰·多伊正开车回新泽西。他穿过两座桥，三区桥和乔治华盛顿大桥，堵在路上两个小时，最后到家时，他儿子骑车压到了他的脚，他妄称了主名。这是大罪吗？这属于严重的事项。但这很严重。但如果你把这种情况带给我，我会说，可能不是。
What you're saying is that context counts.
你的意思是背景很重要。
It does, it does count. But it doesn't necessarily change what you did.
是的，这确实重要。但这并不一定改变你所做的事。
That's also true of intention. Your intentions count. So when Father Torres hears confession, which he does for eight hours a week or more, he asks people what happened, what their intentions were, what the circumstances were, and figures out from that the seriousness of the sin.
动机也是如此。你的意图很重要。所以当托雷斯神父倾听告解时，他每周大约要花八个小时或更多时间做这件事，他会问人们发生了什么，他们的意图是什么，当时的环境是什么，并据此判断罪的严重性。
We sometimes claim ignorance, and that's a place where people say, well, I didn't know. Like, well, you did. If you had an inkling that it was wrong, then you knew. And we have something called a conscience, and a principle that we use-- you never go against an uncertain conscience. So like, if you have a doubt, if this may not be totally right, well, that's your conscience saying, don't do it.
我们有时声称无知，那是人们说“我不知道”的地方。实际上你就是知道。如果你有预感那是错的，那你就是知道。我们有一种东西叫良心，还有一个原则——你永远不能违背不确定的良心。所以，如果你有怀疑，如果不确定这样做是否完全正确，那就是你的良心在说，不要做。
Hm. That's interesting. I've never heard that.
嗯，这很有趣。我从没听过这个。
That's the bread and butter, right there.
这可是看家本领。
That's how you make your living?
这就是你谋生的方式吗？
No, no. But that's a concept that I use often. And this conversation that we're having, I've had 1,000 times.
不，不。但这是一个我经常使用的概念。我们现在进行的这种谈话，我已经进行过一千次了。
So, rule of thumb. If you find yourself wondering if something you did was right or wrong-- probably wrong.
所以，经验法则：如果你发现自己怀疑所做的事情是对是错，那很可能就是错的。
Well, today on our program, we have stories of three people who pretty much know what they are choosing is wrong. They don't even wonder. They know it. But they don't think it's that wrong. They make excuses. They dig themselves in deeper. In short, they act like you and me, and everyone who has ever lived, witnessed-- 77% of Illinois' 10th district, who voted Derrick Smith another term. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述三个人的故事，他们非常清楚自己的选择是错的。他们甚至不需要怀疑。他们知道。但他们并不认为有那么严重。他们找借口。他们越陷越深。简而言之，他们的行为就像你我，以及所有活着的人一样——比如投票给德里克·史密斯再获一任的伊利诺伊州第10选区77%的选民。请留下来。
Act One. The Postcard Always Rings Twice.
第一幕：明信片总会响两次。
So a venial sin, a small sin, just isn't that big of a deal, right? But it turns out, if you keep committing the same venial sin, over and over, if you pile it on, if you escalate, if you become-- in the words of one priest who we talked to this week, "callous of the heart"-- a venial sin can turn into a mortal sin through sheer volume. That is, a not terribly serious event can become a very serious one. Which is more or less what happens in this next story, from Alex Blumberg.
小罪，即轻微的罪，没那么严重，对吧？但事实证明，如果你不停地犯同样的轻罪，一遍又一遍，如果你堆积起来，如果你变本加厉，用我们本周交谈过的一位神父的话说，变得“心肠铁硬”——小罪可能通过量的积累转化为大罪。也就是说，一个本来没那么严重的事情可能变得非常严重。这或多或少就是亚历克斯·布隆伯格带来的下一个故事里发生的事情。
Let's start things off by introducing our sinner.
让我们先介绍一下我们的罪人。
My name is Jeff Smith. I'm from Saint Louis, Missouri. I was an educator there. I worked in the St. Louis City schools. And then I ran for Congress. I lost narrowly. Then I served on the Missouri State Senate for three years, and then I spent last year in federal prison.
我叫杰夫·史密斯。我来自密苏里州圣路易斯。我曾在那里从事教育工作，在圣路易斯市的学校工作过。后来我竞选国会议员，以微弱差距落败。之后我在密苏里州参议院服务了三年，去年我是在联邦监狱度过的。
Now, Jeff Smith will be the first to tell you-- the sin that landed him in federal prison was hardly the worst sin of his life. In fact, among the myriad sins you'll hear about in this story-- sins involving drug dealing, lying to federal agents, attempted murder-- that original sin, the one that landed him in prison, might not even deserve the title of "sin" at all. But I'm getting ahead of myself.
现在，杰夫·史密斯会第一个告诉你——让他入狱的那个罪过绝不是他一生中最严重的罪。事实上，在这个故事中你会听到的无数罪过中——涉及贩毒、向联邦特工撒谎、企图谋杀——那个让他入狱的原罪，可能根本不配被称为“罪”。但我说得太快了。
The story begins in 2003, and starts with, of all people, former Congressman Dick Gephardt from Missouri's 3rd District.
故事始于2003年，主角竟然是来自密苏里州第三选区的前国会议员迪克·格普哈特。
Dick Gephardt, who'd represented the 3rd District for 28 years, had run for president twice, unsuccessfully, but was the leader of the House Democrats, decided to retire.
迪克·格普哈特在第三选区任职28年，曾两次竞选总统未果，但他是众议院民主党领袖，后来决定退休。
And Jeff Smith decided to run for his seat.
于是杰夫·史密斯决定竞选他的席位。
Now, let me just list the ways this was an utterly foolish decision. Jeff Smith was a part-time Political Science professor who'd never held any elected office-- not councilman, not dog catcher, nothing. His opponent in the Democratic primary, on the other hand, Russ Carnahan, came from one of the most prominent political families in the state.
现在，让我列举一下这个决定有多么愚蠢。杰夫·史密斯是一名兼职政治学教授，从未担任过任何民选公职——既不是议员，也不是捕狗官，什么都不是。而他在民主党初选中的对手，拉斯·卡纳汉，来自州内最显赫的政治家族之一。
As the Bushes are to Texas, the Kennedys are to Massachusetts, the Carnahans are to Missouri. Russ' dad, Mel, was the governor of Missouri. He died in a plane crash in 2000 as he was running for Senate. Russ' grandfather also served in politics, a seven-term congressman from Missouri. Russ' mom, Jean, served briefly as a US senator from Missouri, and his sister Robin was Missouri's Secretary of State.
布什家族之于德克萨斯，肯尼迪家族之于马萨诸塞，卡纳汉家族之于密苏里。拉斯的父亲梅尔曾是密苏里州州长，他在2000年竞选参议员时死于空难。拉斯的祖父也从政，是密苏里州连任七届的国会议员。拉斯的母亲琼曾短暂担任过美国参议员，他的妹妹罗宾是密苏里州州务卿。
Add to this that Jeff Smith was 29 years old, 5'6", 120 pounds, with a funny voice and a penchant for baggy, hand-me-down suits. He came across less like a candidate for Congress and more like a well-spoken teenager running for class president. In fact, his own family thought his candidacy was ridiculous.
再加上杰夫·史密斯当时29岁，身高5英尺6英寸，体重120磅，声音滑稽，喜欢穿肥大的二手西装。他看起来不像竞选国会议员，倒更像一个说话老成的少年在竞选班长。事实上，他自己的家人也认为他的参选简直荒谬。
Well actually, I went to dinner at my family's house, and I told my parents and my brother that I planned to run for Congress. And they laughed at me. My brother was imitating Beavis and Butthead. "Uh, if you win, would you like, get Secret Service and stuff?" You know, stuff-- just moronic things like that. My mom said, "What are you running away from? Why don't you just settle down and have a normal life? This is the most absurd thing I've ever heard."
其实，那天我在家里吃晚饭，告诉父母和兄弟我打算竞选国会议员。他们嘲笑我。我兄弟模仿《瘪四与大头蛋》说：“呃，如果你赢了，你会得到特勤局保护之类的吗？”你知道，全是些白痴问题。我妈妈说：“你在逃避什么？为什么不找份工作过正常生活？这是我听过最荒谬的事。”
My Grandma-- she was 95 at the time-- one of her bridge partners received my first solicitation letter. And her bridge partner came to the bridge game and said, "Hey, can I write your grandson a check, you know? Where do I send it?" And my Grandma said, "If I were you, I'd save your money."
我祖母当时95岁。她的牌友之一收到了我的第一封筹款信。她来到牌局问：“嘿，我能给我孙子写张支票吗？我寄到哪去？”我祖母说：“如果我是你，还是省省钱吧。”
Still, there was a method to Jeff's madness. There were 10 candidates competing in the primary, and Jeff figured, as one of the most outspoken and liberal candidates in the pack, he'd be able to stand out, generate just enough votes to eke out a win over the man everyone considered the frontrunner, Russ Carnahan.
尽管如此，杰夫的疯狂中还是有门道的。初选有10名候选人，杰夫心想，作为阵营中最直言不讳和最自由派的候选人，他能够脱颖而出，获得足够的选票，险胜大家公认的领跑者拉斯·卡纳汉。
Jeff had been a very popular part-time professor, and a lot of his former students began to volunteer for his campaign. This volunteer force of 20-somethings grew steadily into one of the biggest and most well-organized ground games in the primary. And Jeff Smith had another valuable asset-- his best friend, Steve Brown.
杰夫是一名非常受欢迎的兼职教授，他的许多学生开始自愿为他竞选。这支由20多岁年轻人组成的志愿者力量稳步壮大，成为初选中最大、组织最严密的地面部队之一。杰夫·史密斯还有另一个宝贵资产——他最好的朋友史蒂夫·布朗。
I guess you would say I was Chairman of the Kitchen Cabinet, so to speak.
我想你会说我是“厨房内阁”的主席。
Steve Brown and Jeff Smith had first met during Steve's failed bid for the state legislature in 2001. Jeff had been Steve's campaign manager. During that campaign, they discovered they were each other's political soulmates. They had the same principles, the same beliefs, the same obsessive interest in the details of political strategy. They would spend hours a night discussing the nuances of messaging, how best to implement a get-out-the-vote campaign, whose political fortunes were rising, and whose were falling. And when Jeff told Steve he was running for Gephardt's seat, Steve-- unlike Jeff's own family-- was immediately behind him.
史蒂夫·布朗和杰夫·史密斯是在2001年史蒂夫竞选州议会失败时认识的。杰夫当时是史蒂夫的竞选经理。在那次竞选中，他们发现彼此是政治上的灵魂伴侣。他们有相同的原则、相同的信仰，对政治策略的细节有同样的痴迷。他们每晚花数小时讨论竞选信息传递的细微差别，如何最好地执行“催票”运动，谁的政治前途正在上升，谁的正在下滑。当杰夫告诉史蒂夫他要竞选格普哈特的席位时，史蒂夫——不像杰夫的家人——立刻全力支持他。
Steve was not an official member of Jeff's campaign, and he had no formal role. But his unofficial role was big, because Steve, unlike Jeff, came from a wealthy and politically connected family.
史蒂夫不是杰夫竞选团队的正式成员，也没有正式职位。但他的非正式角色非常重要，因为史蒂夫和杰夫不同，他来自一个富有且政治关系网深厚的家庭。
My specific goal was attempting to help introduce him to people that would help him raise money. My family had spent a lot of time in Democratic politics in the state and doing other charitable work, as well, and I had access to people that could write him checks, and my job was to put him in front of those people. And that's-- if I had a specific role, that's what I would try to do.
我的具体目标是努力把他介绍给能帮他筹款的人。我的家人在州民主党政治和慈善工作中花费了大量时间，我能接触到那些能开支票的人，我的工作就是让他出现在这些人面前。如果我有一个明确的角色，那就是这样。
One other thing that must be said-- Jeff Smith was a very gifted campaigner. On the trail, he was funny, sincere, great in front of a crowd, whether that crowd was a bunch of liberal college kids at a coffee shop in St. Louis, or a group of wealthy donors in the suburbs. And over the course of the race, Jeff's campaign steadily gained momentum, attracted more volunteers, more money. And professional campaign consultants.
还有一点必须提到——杰夫·史密斯是个非常有天赋的竞选者。在竞选过程中，他幽默、真诚，在人群面前表现极佳，无论是圣路易斯咖啡馆里的一群自由派大学生，还是郊区的富有捐赠者。随着竞选的深入，杰夫的团队势头稳步上升，吸引了更多的志愿者、更多的资金，还有专业的竞选顾问。
One sure sign that your campaign is doing better? More and more professional political types come forward to try and sell you their services. And was an encounter with one of these types that sent Jeff down his windy, improbable path to prison. Here's Jeff.
你的竞选势头良好的一个肯定迹象是什么？越来越多的专业政治人员会主动提出销售他们的服务。正是与其中一人的接触，让杰夫走上了一条通往监狱的漫长而不可能的道路。杰夫说：
We were approached by a man named Skip Ohlsen, who sort of billed himself as a practitioner of political dark arts. He also claimed to be very close to the governor. Apparently he had spent the night in the governor's mansion, had raised money for the governor and lieutenant governor.
有一个叫斯基普·奥尔森的人找到我们，他自诩为“政治暗黑艺术”的实践者。他还声称与州长关系密切。显然，他曾在州长官邸过夜，为州长和副州长筹过款。
Skip presented himself as a seasoned media consultant who wasn't afraid to get his hands dirty, and Jeff said no thanks.
斯基普把自己包装成一个经验丰富、敢于弄脏双手的媒体顾问，但杰夫婉拒了。
But as the campaign heated up and entered its final months, it became clear it wasn't going to be enough for Jeff just to plant more yard signs than his opponent. He needed to attack Carnahan, and Jeff had just the issue he wanted to hit him with.
但随着竞选升温进入最后几个月，很明显，杰夫光靠比对手插更多的院子标牌是不够的。他需要攻击卡纳汉，而杰夫恰好掌握着他想利用的问题。
When Carnahan had served in the state legislature, his attendance record was dismal. He had missed more votes and more days of work than almost any of the state legislators, and had passed no meaningful legislation.
当卡纳汉在州议会任职时，他的出勤记录惨不忍睹。他错过的投票和缺勤天数比州内几乎所有立法者都多，而且没有通过任何有意义的法案。
So when Ohlsen came back to Jeff's campaign to offer his services again, the campaign took him up on it.
所以当奥尔森再次来到杰夫的团队推销服务时，团队接受了。
Two of Jeff's staff members met with Ohlsen and shared Carnahan's attendance data with him. Ohlsen was going to send out direct mailers to voters in the district highlighting his attendance record.
杰夫的两名工作人员与奥尔森会面，并向他分享了卡纳汉的出勤数据。奥尔森打算直接向选区的选民邮寄传单，重点宣传他的出勤记录。
The problem was, Ohlsen was going to do this as an independent expenditure. For those not schooled in the intricacies of election law, an independent expenditure is money that could be spent on ads, mailers, whatever, that is not subject to campaign finance limits. The Swift Boat ads from 2004, targeting John Kerry-- those were independent expenditures. The catch is, there's supposed to be no coordination between the group putting together the independent expenditure and the campaign. So for members of Jeff's staff to be coordinating with Skip Ohlsen on these mailers was illegal-- even if the coordination involved nothing more than supplying him with publicly available data on Carnahan's attendance and voting record.
问题在于，奥尔森打算以“独立支出”的形式来做这件事。对于那些不精通选举法细节的人来说，“独立支出”是指可以用于广告、邮件等方面的资金，它不受竞选财务限制。2004年针对约翰·克里的“快艇老兵”广告，就是独立支出。关键在于，负责独立支出的实体与竞选团队之间不应有任何协调。因此，杰夫的员工与斯基普·奥尔森在这些邮件上协调是违法的——即使协调内容仅仅是向他提供有关卡纳汉出勤和投票记录的公开数据。
Now, Jeff knew all this, but he gave it go-ahead anyway.
杰夫知道这一切，但他还是批准了。
My two staff people came back to me at headquarters. They said, this guy wants to do this independent expenditure. And instead of saying-- I don't want you to meet with him, I said, hey, I don't want to know any of the details. Which was essentially giving tacit permission for them to go and give him that information.
我的两名员工回到总部找我。他们说，这家伙想做这种独立支出。我没有说“我不希望你们和他见面”，而是说，嘿，我不想知道细节。这本质上是在默许他们去提供信息。
This was Jeff's first sin. The minute he knew that his staff were coordinating to produce an independent expenditure, he was complicit in this illegal act, and he knew that. But as sins go, especially political sins, it didn't seem that bad-- the political equivalent of jaywalking. Jeff figured, this is the sort of thing that happens all the time.
这是杰夫的第一个罪过。从他知道员工为了制作独立支出而进行协调的那一刻起，他就成为了这个非法行为的同谋，他对此心知肚明。但作为罪行，尤其是政治罪，这看起来没那么严重——相当于政治上的乱穿马路。杰夫认为，这种事每天都在发生。
The campaign put Ohlsen in touch with Steve Brown, who found some money to pay him. And that part was legal, by the way. Remember, Steve Brown was not an official member of Jeff's campaign. And then everyone went back about their business. Here's Jeff Smith.
竞选团队让奥尔森与史蒂夫·布朗取得了联系，史蒂夫找到了一些钱付给他。顺便说一句，这部分是合法的。记住，史蒂夫·布朗不是杰夫竞选团队的正式成员。然后大家各忙各的。杰夫·史密斯说：
Over the course of the whole campaign, I didn't think about it for more than 15 minutes, probably.
在整个竞选过程中，我可能都没想过这件事超过15分钟。
It was just one more decision in a long string of decisions you make every day.
这只是你每天做出的那一长串决定中的一个。
Yeah, you make thousands of decisions. And my focus was 600 volunteers, making sure that I had 20 full-time interns who were all college kids or high school kids, and I had a great field director-- I wanted to make sure they were all knocking on doors. I needed to raise the money to make sure that we could get up on black radio, that we could do TV ads, that we could fill out our direct mail program. I mean, really, I doubted that it would ever happen, because I didn't view Skip Ohlsen as being a credible person, and I doubted that he'd ever follow through with it.
是的，你会做出成千上万个决定。我的焦点是600名志愿者，确保我有20名全是大学生或高中生的全职实习生，我还有一位伟大的现场主管——我只想确保他们都在挨家挨户敲门。我需要筹钱确保我们能上黑人电台，能做电视广告，能完成直接邮寄计划。老实说，我怀疑这事儿根本成不了，因为我认为斯基普·奥尔森不是个靠谱的人，我怀疑他根本不会执行。
For weeks and weeks, it seemed Jeff was right to doubt. But then, in the final days of the campaign, Skip sent out the mailers-- postcards to addresses all over the district, highlighting Carnahan's attendance record. Jeff didn't even know the mailers had gone out until Jeff's press secretary got ahold of one.
好几个星期，杰夫似乎都猜对了。但在竞选的最后几天，斯基普发出了邮件——寄往全区各处的明信片，重点宣传了卡纳汉的出勤记录。杰夫甚至在新闻秘书拿到一张之前，都不知道邮件已经发出去了。
He shows it to me, and it was this amateurish thing. I mean, it looked like a seventh grader did it at the last minute, after procrastinating for three weeks on his end of the semester project. It was not well-done. And we immediately noticed that it lacked a disclaimer.
他拿给我看，那是件业余货。看起来就像个七年级学生在学期末项目拖了三周后最后一分钟赶出来的。做得非常差。我们立刻注意到上面缺少免责声明。
That is, that little thing at the end of all political ads-- "Paid For By Citizens for Fairness," or "Taxpayers for Justice." So the way an independent expenditure is supposed to work-- a separate entity is formed and registered with the Federal Elections Committee, the body in charge of federal election law. And the name of that entity is supposed to be present on all the political materials it sends out. Here's Steve Brown.
也就是所有政治广告结尾处的那行小字——“由公平公民组织支付”或“纳税人正义委员会支付”。独立支出应该是这样运作的：一个单独的实体成立并向联邦选举委员会（负责联邦选举法的机构）注册。该实体的名称应该出现在其发送的所有政治宣传材料上。史蒂夫·布朗说：
And for whatever reason, I certainly didn't know that he was going to do it. He put on there sort of a bogus disclaimer, saying "Paid For by RustyCarnahan.org." OK? I don't know why he did it. If he had put the regular thing on there, and they had found out that I was involved, it wouldn't have bothered me in the slightest. We didn't want him to do that. He did that.
不管出于什么原因，我当然不知道他会那么做。他在上面放了一个虚假的免责声明，写着“由RustyCarnahan.org支付”。好吧？我不知道他为什么要那样做。如果他写了正规的，而他们发现我参与了，我也一点都不会介意。我们不想让他那么做。是他自己做的。
And what was he supposed to say? Paid for by--? What was it supposed to say?
那他本来应该写什么？由……支付？
"Voters for Truth," which was just a entity that he had created to conduct business.
“真实选民”，这是他为了开展业务而创建的实体。
But that was the entity that has all the T's crossed and the I's dotted and all that sort of stuff. It was legal, basically.
但那才是所有手续齐备的合法实体。
Yes. It was a committee, or it was an independent expenditure, set up properly.
是的。这是一个设置妥当的委员会或独立支出实体。
Putting a disclaimer on a political mailing is a pretty basic thing. To this day it's unclear why Skip Ohlsen didn't do it. But since he hadn't, there were now 25,000 disclaimerless postcards out there, and the amount of damage that that one omission opened the door to was truly staggering.
在政治邮件上贴免责声明是非常基本的事。直到今天，还不清楚斯基普·奥尔森为什么没那么做。但既然他没做，现在就有25000张缺少免责声明的明信片流向了选民，而这一疏漏所带来的损害简直是惊人的。
What happened, in this case, is that Russ Carnahan also noticed that the mailer lacked a disclaimer. He noticed Jeff Smith holding press conferences raising the same exact point about his attendance record as the mailer did, and he probably noticed, as well, that when you clicked on RustyCarnahan.org, you came to a page with an illustration of a barefooted person on a beach, napping in a hammock.
在这种情况下，发生的事是拉斯·卡纳汉也注意到了邮件缺少免责声明。他注意到杰夫·史密斯在新闻发布会上提出的关于他出勤记录的观点与邮件上的完全一致，而且他也可能注意到，当你点击RustyCarnahan.org时，进入的页面上画着一个光脚人在沙滩上的吊床上打盹。
And so with roughly a week before the election, he filed a formal complaint with the FEC, saying essentially, here's this illegal mailer. I think Jeff Smith is behind it. Investigate, please.
于是，在离选举还有一周左右的时候，他向联邦选举委员会提交了正式投诉，本质上是说：这是违法的邮件。我认为杰夫·史密斯是幕后黑手。请调查。
And then, about a week later, election night came. The race was much closer than anyone thought it would be. At several points during the night, it looked like Jeff might actually win. But in the end, he was edged out by Russ Carnahan. Final margin of victory, less than 2000 votes.
然后，大约一周后，选举之夜到了。选情比任何人预想的都要胶着。当晚有几次，看起来杰夫真的可能会赢。但最后，他以不到2000张选票的差距输给了拉斯·卡纳汉。
A day or two later, Jeff met with Russ Carnahan in the obligatory water-under-the-bridge post-primary fence-mending session.
一两天后，杰夫与拉斯·卡纳汉举行了选后例行的“既往不咎”握手言和会议。
I said hey, congratulations, you won. I'm happy to help you now in the general election. I want to make sure a Democrat holds this seat. I'll endorse you. I can do it publicly, I can do a press release, whatever you want. I'll raise money for you, I'll knock on doors for you, I'll ask my volunteers to knock on doors for you.
我说，嘿，恭喜你赢了。我现在很乐意在大选中帮你。我想确保民主党能保住这个席位。我会支持你。我可以公开支持，发新闻稿，随便你怎么要求。我会为你筹款，帮你敲门，我会要求我的志愿者为你敲门。
He said, great. I said, I do have one request. I'd love it if you dropped that FEC complaint. And my support will not hinge on your decision. I'll still be happy to do those things. But as a gesture of goodwill, I'd appreciate it if you dropped the complaint.
他说，太好了。我说，我有一个请求。如果你能撤销那个FEC投诉，我会很高兴。我的支持不会取决于你的决定。我还是很乐意做那些事。但作为善意的表示，如果你能撤销投诉，我会很感激。
And he looked at his brother, and his brother said, I'm sorry, but I'm afraid the missile's already left the silo.
他看了看他的兄弟，他兄弟说，对不起，但我恐怕导弹已经发射了。
Sometime later, Jeff received a copy of the FEC complaint in the mail. He showed it to his lawyer, and she prepared an affidavit for him to sign-- an affidavit claiming Jeff Smith had no knowledge of who was behind the postcard. This, of course, was not true, but Jeff signed it anyway.
一段时间后，杰夫收到了一份FEC投诉的副本。他拿给律师看，律师准备了一份宣誓书让他签字——宣誓书中声称杰夫·史密斯对谁是明信片的幕后黑手一无所知。这当然不是事实，但杰夫还是签了。
Now, this was a big step, making a false statement on an affidavit in response to a federal investigation. That took him out of wrist slap territory and into potential prison territory. But Jeff didn't really appreciate the magnitude of this much larger crime, because it was still linked in his mind too that smaller, original one-- that technically illegal coordination over a postcard.
现在，这是一大步，在联邦调查中对宣誓书做出虚假陈述。这让他从挨巴掌的范围进入了潜在的监狱范围。但杰夫并没有真正意识到这个更大的罪行的严重程度，因为在他的脑海里，它仍然与那个更小的原始罪行联系在一起——那种在明信片上进行的非法协调。
And plus, the campaign was over. He'd lost. He knew he'd never do anything like this again if it left a bad taste in his mouth the first time. He was worried about implicating his staff people who'd met with Skip Ohlsen, and he was already in debt from his race and worried about paying a potential fine himself.
而且，竞选已经结束了。他输了。他知道如果第一次尝试让他感到不快，他就再也不会做这种事了。他担心牵连与斯基普·奥尔森会面的员工，而且他竞选已经负债，担心自己还要支付潜在的罚款。
And so for a variety of reasons, none of which I say to excuse my terrible mistake, I just went ahead and signed it. I just figured-- I did an instant calculation in my head. I know there's hundreds, if not thousands, of these situations across the country, every election cycle. There's always accusations of coordination. Most of the time they're probably right, but it's probably not provable. And I assume this complaint will just fall into that huge stack that they'll look into, not be able to figure anything out definitively, and-- you know, that will be that.
所以出于种种原因，我并没有说这些能为我的可怕错误辩解，我还是签了。我只是在头脑里做了一个快速计算。我知道全国每届选举周期都有成百上千起这种情况。总有关于协调的指控。大多数时候可能是对的，但可能无法证实。我假设这个投诉只会掉进他们要调查的那大堆文件里，他们查不出什么确切的东西，然后……你知道，那就是那样了。
And in fact, for two years, basically nothing happened with the FEC case. During that time, Jeff made another bid for elected office, this one successful, and got himself elected to the Missouri State Senate.
事实上，FEC案件基本上两年什么都没发生。在此期间，杰夫又竞选了一次公职，这次成功了，当选为密苏里州参议员。
And then, about right after I got elected to the Missouri Senate, things heated up again. And Skip called my friend Steve Brown and said, they want to talk to me. And Steve called me and told me that. And he said, they're going to talk to Skip, but don't worry. I'll take care of Skip.
然后，我刚当选密苏里参议员后不久，事情又闹大了。斯基普给我的朋友史蒂夫·布朗打电话说，他们想和我谈谈。史蒂夫打电话告诉了我。他说，他们要和斯基普谈，但别担心，我会搞定斯基普。
I talked to him, and had a long conversation with him.
我和他谈过，进行了一次长谈。
Again, Steve Brown. He says he tried to convince Ohlsen not to say anything to the FEC.
依然是史蒂夫·布朗。他说他试图说服奥尔森不要向FEC透露任何信息。
And I hung the carrot out there of working on future campaigns with me and Jeff, and making some money, if he were to sort of fall on his sword and have this investigation end with him.
我抛出了和他及杰夫合作未来竞选并赚钱的诱饵，如果他能“慷慨就义”，让调查终结于他那里的话。
And did you think that he was going to do that?
你当时认为他会那么做吗？
I was not 100% confident that he was going to do that.
我并没有百分之百的把握。
Now at this point, Steve Brown was an Assistant Attorney General for the state of Missouri, so he of all people knew that it was illegal to do what he was doing-- to try to get Ohlsen to lie to the FEC. But he says he was thinking about it not like a lawyer, but a politician-- the same way Jeff was. That original infraction was so minor and technical-- about a postcard.
现在，史蒂夫·布朗是密苏里州助理总检察长，所以他比任何人都清楚自己所做的是违法的——试图让奥尔森向FEC撒谎。但他表示自己当时不是以律师的身份思考，而是以政治家的身份，就像杰夫一样。最初的那次违规是如此微小且技术性——关于一张明信片。
And there was a lot at stake now. He and Jeff both had exceeded everyone's expectations with that campaign. Their political fortunes were on the rise. Steve was worried that an FEC violation would damage all that.
而且现在赌注很大。他和杰夫在竞选中都超出了所有人的预期，他们的政治前途正在上升。史蒂夫担心FEC的违规行为会损害这一切。
And he figured, who would ever find out about a private conversation like this, anyway? Plus, it's not like the FEC has a reputation for aggressively pursuing campaign finance violations. Many people consider it a bit of a joke as an enforcement agency.
而且他认为，谁会查到这样的私人谈话呢？再说，FEC作为执法机构在名声上并不怎么激进。许多人认为它只是个笑话。
And for about a year after Ohlsen talked to the FEC, nothing happened. During that time, Steve Brown left his job in the Attorney General's office and also got himself elected to the state legislature, on the House side, so now he and Jeff were going to be serving together. Things were going great.
在奥尔森与FEC交谈后，大约有一年什么事都没发生。在此期间，史蒂夫·布朗离开了检察长办公室，也当选了州众议员，所以现在他和杰夫要在州议会共事了。一切都很顺利。
And then, in the winter of 2007, the FEC came out with its report saying they were dropping the case. Skip Ohlsen was just too unreliable a witness. Steve Brown recalls getting the news.
然后，在2007年冬天，FEC发布报告称他们要结案了。斯基普·奥尔森是个太不可靠的证人。史蒂夫·布朗回忆起得到消息的情景。
Jeff called me up and said, I've got a present for you. I've got to come by and show it to you. And he becomes by and gives me a copy of the final report that closes the matter, and I say to him, boy, I think we really dodged a bullet on this one. And at that particular point in time, I did think this was over.
杰夫打电话来说，我有一份礼物给你。我得过去让你看看。他过来给了我一份终结此事的最终报告，我说，老兄，我觉得我们这次真的躲过一劫。在那一刻，我确实以为结束了。
In fact, reading the report, it only reinforced the notion that the FEC wasn't much of an investigative body. They never even talked to Steve Brown, although he did see his name mentioned.
事实上，阅读报告只会强化这样一种观念：FEC不是什么调查机构。他们甚至没找过史蒂夫·布朗，尽管他确实看到了自己的名字被提及。
A footnote in the investigation said, "Skip Ohlsen says Steve Brown helped provide the money for this effort." Something along the lines of, "We doubt that this person even exists." "We've been unable to locate him and doubt that he even exists." And at that particular time, when the FEC wrote that, my name was on the ballot in Missouri. But be that as it may, they closed their investigation at that point.
调查中的一个脚注写道：“斯基普·奥尔森说史蒂夫·布朗帮忙提供了资金。”类似“我们怀疑此人是否存在”的话。“我们无法定位他，怀疑他是否存在。”而在那个特定时刻，当FEC写下这些时，我的名字就在密苏里州的选票上。但无论如何，他们当时结案了。
And that is the point where the matter would have died-- if not for one of the strangest and most random twists you could imagine.
而这本来是这件事终结的地方——如果不是因为一段你能想象出的最奇怪、最随机的转折的话。
Late afternoon on a Wednesday in October 2008, a 69-year-old attorney found a wicker basket next to his car, an Acura, in the parking garage of his office. When he picked up the basket, it exploded, severely burning his hands and face. The police could find no motive. This man didn't seem like the type of guy who would provoke an attempt on his life. Who's trying to kill him?
2008年10月一个星期三的深夜，一位69岁的律师在他的办公室停车场发现车旁有一个柳条篮。当他拿起篮子时，它爆炸了，严重烧伤了他的手和脸。警察找不到动机。这看起来不像那种会引来杀身之祸的人。谁在试图杀他？
They didn't find any suspects, but they did discover that there was another Acura, often parked in that same garage, just a floor away. And this Acura belonged to a divorce attorney-- a divorce attorney who happened to represent the estranged ex-wife of one Skip Ohlsen, the practitioner of the political dark arts. Steve called Jeff with the news.
他们没发现任何嫌疑人，但他们确实发现同一停车场离那儿就隔一层楼的地方停着另一辆讴歌。这辆讴歌的主人是一位离婚律师——恰好代理了斯基普·奥尔森的前妻，那个搞政治黑活儿的人的离婚官司。史蒂夫把新闻告诉了杰夫。
He called me one day right after session and told me that Skip Ohlsen was being investigated for a car bombing of Skip's ex-wife's divorce attorney. And we were just like, oh my god. And then Steve told me that Skip was also being investigated for illegal weapons possession, and mortgage fraud, and bank fraud, and had also been convicted before of cocaine distribution and domestic violence, domestic abuse. Just a whole litany of things. And we had thought, had a hunch, that Skip was a little bit shady, but we, of course, had no idea of all of that.
会期结束后他立刻打电话给我，说斯基普·奥尔森因涉嫌炸弹袭击前妻的离婚律师而被调查。我们当时想，哦天哪。然后史蒂夫告诉我，斯基普还因非法持有武器、抵押贷款欺诈和银行欺诈被调查，而且之前就有可卡因贩运和家庭暴力的前科。简直是一长串罪行。我们之前以为，隐约觉得斯基普是个阴险角色，但当然，我们对他所有的事一无所知。
You didn't think that he was capable of murder?
你没想过他有谋杀能力吗？
No.
没有。
Jeff worried, what if Skip tries to cut a plea deal by saying, "I have damaging information about two state lawmakers"? So he and Steve met to talk it over.
杰夫担心，如果斯基普试图通过说“我掌握两名州议员的破坏性信息”来达成认罪协议怎么办？于是他和史蒂夫见面讨论了这件事。
Well, Steve comes to my house, and one of my former staffers from 2004 comes over, and we discuss how we're going to handle the situation. I say, hey, I'm already out there. I signed an affidavit, OK, saying I didn't know anything about this. So I'm just going to stick to that. And Nick Adams, my first staff person in 2004-- Nick said, "Hey, this is the word of one cocaine-distributing, wife-beating convicted felon against the word of a state representative and lawyer"-- Steve Brown-- "and political science professor and state senator. Who are they going to believe?" And I agreed with that. And I said, "I think we should just stick to the story."
史蒂夫来到我家，我2004年的一个前工作人员也来了，我们讨论如何处理这个局面。我说，嘿，我已经深陷其中了，我签了一份宣誓书，说我对这个一无所知。所以我打算坚持这个说法。尼克·亚当斯，我在2004年的第一个员工说：“嘿，这是一个贩运可卡因、殴打妻子的罪犯对阵州众议员和律师——史蒂夫·布朗——以及政治学教授和州参议员的话。他们会相信谁？”我表示赞同。我说：“我认为我们应该坚持那个版本。”
So Steve he called me several times over the course of a couple months, and we met in person and discussed all of this frequently. And little did I know that that entire time, he was wearing a wire.
史蒂夫在那几个月里给我打了好几次电话，我们经常亲自见面讨论这些。但我一点都不知道，那整段时间，他都戴着窃听器。
So when you were meeting at your house, he was wearing a wire. He had you on tape saying--
所以当你们在家里见面时，他戴着窃听器。他录下了你说——
He had me on tape saying the following. I said something to the effect of, "Did I know that Skip was going to do that postcard? No, I didn't know. But I guess you could say that I had a pretty good hunch." So I say something to that effect, something pretty close to that, on tape.
他录下了我这样说。我说过类似这样的话：“我知道斯基普会做那张明信片吗？不，我不知道。但我猜你可以说我有相当强烈的预感。”所以我在录音里说了类似的话，非常接近这些。
So why, you might be wondering, was Steve Brown taping this conversation? Well, it turns out that three years earlier, when Steve had had that conversation with Skip Ohlsen-- the one where he tried to keep him from testifying to the FEC-- the conversation in which he'd promised material rewards if Ohlsen lied to federal investigators-- during that conversation, Skip Ohlsen had been wearing a wire on Steve. When the Feds went to investigate Ohlsen for his various illegal activities, they found this recording, along with a stack of other ones. It appeared surreptitiously recording people with whom he was conducting business was a bit of a habit of Skip Ohlsen's.
所以，你可能会好奇，史蒂夫·布朗为什么要录下这次谈话？事实证明，三年前当史蒂夫和斯基普·奥尔森进行那次谈话时——他试图让他不要向FEC作证——在那次谈话中，他承诺如果奥尔森向联邦调查人员撒谎，就会有物质奖励——在谈话过程中，斯基普·奥尔森一直戴着窃听器。当联邦人员调查奥尔森的非法活动时，他们发现了这段录音，以及其他一堆录音。看起来秘密录下和他做生意的人是斯基普·奥尔森的一种习惯。
Sometime after discovering these recordings, FBI agents approached Steve as he was leaving his house. Steve contacted his lawyer. His lawyer found out about the recordings, and came back with some very bad news for Steve.
在发现这些录音后不久，联邦调查局特工在史蒂夫离开家时接近了他。史蒂夫联系了律师。律师查清了录音，并带回了对史蒂夫来说非常糟糕的消息。
He said, you are in very big trouble. There's going to be a felony conviction. You're going to lose your law license. You're going to lose your political career. The job now is to try to keep you out of jail. So that came down instantaneously.
他说，你陷入了大麻烦。会有重罪判决。你会失去律师执照。你会失去政治生涯。现在的工作是尝试让你免于入狱。所以消息瞬间就传开了。
Steve says that right at that moment, his attorney laid out the strategy for keeping Steve out of jail.
史蒂夫说，就在那一刻，他的律师制定了让他免于入狱的策略。
And of course, that includes assisting the federal government in building their case against Jeff.
当然，这包括协助联邦政府建立针对杰夫的案件。
You know, here I was. I mean-- Jeff and I, over the years, would talk four hours-- OK-- into the middle of the night, on the phone constantly. And here I was, going to have one of those conversations with Jeff, knowing that the purpose was to get him to say things to incriminate himself, that would ultimately get him prosecuted.
你知道，我当时就是这样。我和杰夫这些年来会聊上四小时，一直聊到深夜，电话不停。而我当时不得不和杰夫进行其中一次对话，知道目的是让他说出 incriminating（自我定罪）的话，最终导致他被起诉。
And what are your thoughts? I mean, what were you thinking at that time?
你的想法是什么？当时你在想什么？
Uh--it's really very hard to put into words. These were-- it was a dark, dark day. I mean, this is a crappy situation. And if Jeff were sitting across from me right now, I'd apologize to him for doing it. But it was clearly what was going to happen.
呃……真的很难用语言表达。那是黑暗，黑暗的一天。我的意思是，这是一个糟糕透顶的情况。如果杰夫现在坐在我对面，我会为做过的事向他道歉。但那是显然会发生的事。
I had lost my life for Jeff. OK? I lost my political career. I lost my law license. I lost reputation. And I lost all that in an attempt to help Jeff. And that was as far as I was prepared to go. To be honest-- sorry, Jeff. Ah-- you're a good guy. I had hoped and planned to do great things with you. But I'm not-- I'm not risking, I'm not taking away from my two children and my wife for you or anybody else. And so thinking about them is what really got me thinking, what I needed to do to keep myself out of jail.
我为了杰夫失去了我的人生。我失去了政治生涯。失去了律师执照。失去了声誉。我失去了这一切都是为了帮杰夫。那是我的底线。说实话——对不起，杰夫。啊……你是个好人。我曾希望并计划和你一起做伟大的事情。但我没打算……我不会为了你或者任何人去牺牲我的两个孩子和我的妻子。所以想到他们才让我真正意识到我需要做什么来让自己免于入狱。
It turns out, being a great cooperating witness and someone's closest friend-- there's a lot of overlap. Steve and Jeff would talk about Skip Ohlsen's investigation, and Steve would ask Jeff, what are you going to do if they come to your house?
事实证明，作为伟大的合作证人和某人最亲密的朋友，重叠之处很多。史蒂夫和杰夫会谈论斯基普·奥尔森的调查，史蒂夫会问杰夫，如果他们到你家怎么办？
I say at one point on the tape, "i'm going to be 90% honest with them." So right there-- there's a count of obstruction of justice.
我在录音里有一处说：“我会对他们90%诚实。”所以就在那里……有一个妨碍司法罪的计数。
Right.
对。
In the end, Jeff was charged with nine counts. On the day the Feds came to his door and charged him, he went to his lawyer's office.
最终，杰夫被控九项罪名。在联邦人员来到他家门前对他控罪的那天，他去了律师办公室。
Then she called the US Attorney's Office, and she came back 10 minutes later, and sat me down with another attorney, and said-- you know, your best friend has been wearing a wire for the last couple months, and you're probably going to go to prison.
然后她打电话给联邦检察官办公室，十分钟后回来，让我和另一位律师坐下，说……你知道，你最好的朋友过去几个月一直戴着窃听器，你很可能要进监狱。
So I drove to my parents' house. I called him, told them I needed to come over and talk to them. It's only about five minutes away, but it was probably the longest five minutes in my life. And I told them, hey, guys, listen. I made a big mistake in my first campaign, and immediately afterwards, and I'm probably going to go to prison. And let me explain what I did.
于是我开车去了父母家。我给他们打电话，说我得过去和他们谈谈。只有五分钟路程，但那可能是我生命中最长的五分钟。我告诉他们，嘿，爸妈，听着。我在第一次竞选中犯了个大错，在那之后也是，我可能要进监狱。让我解释我做了什么。
And my mom's response was, "I probably could have predicted"-- she said, "I knew this was going to happen. I told you that politics is dirty. I told you not to get mixed up in this. I told you that you shouldn't have ever run for office." Maybe not what I needed to hear right at that moment, but I understood where she was coming from, because she had been the loudest voice from the start, telling me it was the stupidest idea she'd ever heard, for me to run for office.
我妈的回答是：“我大概能预料到。”她说，“我知道会这样。我告诉你政治是肮脏的。我告诉你不要卷进去。我告诉你你不该竞选公职。”那可能不是我当时最想听到的，但我理解她的立场，因为从一开始她就是最大声阻止我的人，说这是我听过最蠢的主意。
Jeff was sent to federal prison in Kentucky to serve his one-year sentence. He stood out in many ways there-- 5'6", 120 pounds, white, PhD. Plus, he was one of the few people in the facility not serving a drug sentence. In fact, his fellow inmates had a hard time figuring out-- wait, how exactly did you wind up here?
杰夫被送往肯塔基州的联邦监狱服刑一年。他在那里有很多显眼之处——身高5英尺6英寸，体重120磅，白人，博士。此外，他是设施中极少数不是因为毒品罪入狱的人。事实上，他的狱友很难弄清楚……等等，你到底是怎么进来的？
They thought I, like, embezzled millions. They're like, "Man, you pulled some Blago [BLEEP]." You know, because the Blagojevich stuff was happening. I'm like, "I didn't get any." They're like,"Then why'd you end up here?" I'm like, "It wasn't about money." They're like, "man"-- and they'd always be like, "what the [BLEEP]'s wrong with you? You end up in prison, you didn't even get no money?"
他们以为我像挪用了几百万。他们说，“伙计，你搞了些布拉戈[消音]的事。”你知道，因为布拉戈耶维奇的事当时在闹。我说，“我什么都没拿到。”他们说，“那你怎么进来的？”我说，“这不是关于钱。”他们说，“老兄”——他们总会说，“你是有什么[消音]毛病吗？你进了监狱，甚至连钱都没捞着？”
They thought I was really stupid. I mean, they thought I was really stupid. They're like, I'm in prison for a postcard?
他们觉得我真的很蠢。我是说，他们觉得我真的蠢透了。他们心想，我因为一张明信片进监狱？
During his time in prison, Jeff had a lot of time to think about that postcard-- his own mistakes in allowing it to happen, but also the utterly improbable chain of coincidences that allowed that postcard to come back and get him. If Skip Ohlsen had just put the proper disclaimer on that postcard, for starters, identifying the organization that he had, in fact, gone to the trouble to properly set up. Or if Skip Ohlsen hadn't tried to car bomb his ex-wife's divorce attorney. Or if he hadn't had a penchant for surreptitiously recording conversations with business partners. Take out any one of those things, and Jeff Smith wouldn't have been sitting in his prison cell.
在监狱期间，杰夫有很多时间思考那张明信片——他自己允许它发生的错误，以及那一连串让明信片回来抓住他的一系列不可思议的巧合。如果斯基普·奥尔森一开始就在明信片上贴上适当的免责声明，标明他确实费力设立的组织；或者如果斯基普·奥尔森没有试图用炸弹炸毁前妻的离婚律师；或者如果他没有偷偷录下与商业伙伴谈话的爱好。拿掉其中任何一个，杰夫·史密斯就不会坐在监狱牢房里。
And then there was Steve Brown, his best friend who'd worn the wire. It's a hard thing to get over. In the beginning, Jeff says, he had a lot of bitterness towards Steve. But early on, Jeff found a mentor at the prison-- a former drug dealer serving a multi-year sentence nicknamed KY. KY overheard Jeff talking about Steve Brown to some other inmates.
然后还有史蒂夫·布朗，那个戴着窃听器的最好朋友。这很难释怀。杰夫说，起初他对比史蒂夫有很多苦涩。但很早之前，杰夫在监狱里发现了一位导师——一位绰号KY的因毒品罪服刑多年的前毒贩。KY听见杰夫在和其他狱友谈论史蒂夫·布朗。
KY soon thereafter took me aside, because somebody had asked me, in a group setting-- kind of jokingly asked me, "Hey, man, let me get after your boy." "I have someone get after your boy." Basically joking around, saying, hey, we can have someone go do something to Steve Brown. And I was sort of humoring him, like, what are they going to do to him?
KY随后把我拉到一边，因为有一次在小组活动中，有人开玩笑问我，“嘿，伙计，让我收拾你那哥们儿。”“找人收拾你那哥们儿。”基本上是在开玩笑说，我们可以找人去对史蒂夫·布朗做点什么。我当时有点顺着他说，比如他们要对他做什么？
And KY took me aside and said, man, you got to put that dude out of your mind. Don't even think about him. He's like, my brother-in-law told and got me here. He's like, my first year, that's all I could think about. What I was going to that [BLEEP] when I got out. And he's like, you can't do time like that. You see these other dudes-- all they're doing is worrying about the dude who told on them, and what they're going to do to him when they get out. And he's like, you can't get through your time. You've got to focus on positive stuff.
KY把我拉到一边说，伙计，你得把那家伙从脑子里赶出去。连想都别想他。他说，我妹夫告发了我，把我送进这儿。他说，我第一年满脑子想的都是那件事。想我出去后要对那个[消音]做什么。他说，你不能那样服刑。你看看其他人……他们整天想的都是告发他们的人，出去后要对他做什么。他说，那样你撑不过刑期。你得专注于积极的事情。
What happens if we don't?
如果我们不那样做会怎样？
There's too much-- you just eat yourself up. Like, you go back in your cell at night, and you're just sitting there, thinking about it. You can't do that. You can't get through-- I had this little bit of time, compared to those guys. Most of those guys had 10, 15 years. It's just a miserable experience. It's just miserable being away from the people you love-- and prison sucks.
会消耗太多……你会把自己吃掉。就像，你晚上回到牢房，只是坐在那里想这件事。你不能那样。你不能……相比那些家伙，我刑期还算短的。他们大多数有10年、15年。那是一段悲惨的经历。远离你爱的人非常痛苦——监狱糟透了。
And it sucked even more, precisely for the reason that prison is supposed to suck. He had time to think about what he'd done.
而且它更糟，恰恰是因为监狱就是为了糟才存在的。他有时间思考他所做的事。
And there was a lot to jog his memory in the transcripts of the secret recordings Steve Brown made. At a certain point during the several months in which Steve Brown is recording, the Feds approach Jeff and question him. Jeff lies to them about what he knows about Skip Ohlsen. Later in conversation with Steve Brown, he goes back and forth about what he should have done. At one point he says, quote, "Do you think I made a huge mistake today, telling them I didn't know who did the mailer? If I called them back, would that change things?" But then later in the same conversation, he tells Steve, if the feds come and interview you, quote, "Can you just shade it at all?"
史蒂夫·布朗录下的秘密录音笔录里有很多能唤起他记忆的东西。在史蒂夫·布朗录音的几个月里，联邦人员接近杰夫并审问他。杰夫对斯基普·奥尔森的情况向他们撒谎。后来在与史蒂夫·布朗谈话时，他反复考虑自己本该怎么做。有一处他说：“你认为我今天告诉他们我不知道是谁做的传单犯了巨大错误吗？如果我再打回去，会改变什么吗？”但在同一次谈话中，他又告诉史蒂夫，如果联邦人员来采访你，“你能稍微修饰一下吗？”
During another moment, he appeals to Steve to blame the whole thing on one of his staffers who had coordinated with Skip Ohlsen, who had since died. Another time he tells Steve, quote, "I hate to say this. The only way they can get me is if you or Nick"-- another former staff member-- "says something."
在另一个时刻，他请求史蒂夫把所有事都归咎于一位已经去世的、曾与斯基普·奥尔森协调过的员工。又有一次他告诉史蒂夫：“我讨厌说这个。他们唯一能抓到我的方法就是你或者尼克——另一个前员工——说了些什么。”
And when Steve refers on tape to the conversation he had with Skip Ohlsen where he tried to get him to lie to the FEC, Jeff says, quote, "You can't tell them that." And quote, "You'd be an utter fool to tell them you crossed over the line."
当史蒂夫在录音中提到他和斯基普·奥尔森那次试图让他对FEC撒谎的谈话时，杰夫说：“你不能告诉他们那个。”还有，“如果你告诉他们你越界了，那真是个彻头彻尾的傻瓜。”
To Steve Brown, it felt like he was the one being betrayed by his best friend.
对史蒂夫·布朗来说，感觉自己才是被最好朋友背叛的那个人。
There were times when it was clear to Jeff that the heat was on. The FBI had visited him. He now knew that extreme consequences were attaching to our actions, and the only thing that came to his mind during that time was to continue to tell me to lie and put myself at risk. I mean, what if he had said, Steve, I love you, you're my best friend, I can't ask you to do this anymore, I'm going to go talk to these people and see what I can get done? He never said that. All he could tell me to do was lie.
有几次杰夫很清楚局势很严峻。FBI找过他。他现在知道我们的行为将带来极端后果，而在那段时间里，他脑子里想的唯一一件事就是继续告诉我撒谎，让我自己承担风险。我是说，如果他当时说，史蒂夫，我爱你，你是我的好朋友，我不能再让你做这些了，我要去找这些人看看能怎么解决？他从没说过。他只会告诉我撒谎。
I understand why he would feel betrayed by that.
我理解为什么他会感到被背叛。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I mean, it was not a good moment for me, you know?
真的。那是我的一个糟糕时刻，你知道吗？
Why didn't you tell him that, though, do you think? Don't worry-- protect yourself, basically? Talk to the Feds if you need to, et cetera?
你为什么不告诉他呢，你觉得？别担心……保护好你自己，基本上？如果需要的话去找联邦调查局，等等？
Alex, man, if you talked to 1,000 people in the world that were in a situation at all similar to what I was in-- and you asked 1,000 of them-- tell me the truth, why didn't you go to one of the only other people that could've gotten you, and go to the Feds, and just tell them whatever it was-- I don't think you're going to find many of those 1,000 that will honestly tell you-- yeah, I should've gone to tell them, hey, go to the Feds, and tell them anything, everything that happened. I just don't think you're going to see that much.
亚历克斯，如果世界上有1000个处于和我类似情况的人——你问他们，跟我说实话，为什么你没去找那个能抓到你的人之一，去联邦调查局，把所有发生的事告诉他们——我不认为你会找到很多会诚实告诉你“是的，我应该去找他们，告诉他们，嘿，去联邦调查局，把发生的一切都告诉他们”。我不觉得你能看到那么多。
I mean, you feel like you're hunted prey when the Feds come knocking on your door at 6:30 in the morning. And you're right. Of course I should have been like, Steve, you do what you need to do. But I felt sort of like-- we had made this agreement long ago, and for any one of us to go soft now was to get us all into trouble.
我是说，当联邦调查局早上6点半来敲门时，你感觉自己就像被猎捕的猎物。你说得对。我当然应该说：史蒂夫，做你需要做的事。但我当时感觉……我们很久以前达成了这个协议，我们中任何一个人现在认怂，都会让所有人惹上麻烦。
I mean, the way we talk about it, it's like there were six dead bodies in vacant houses somewhere. I mean, it's just so silly. I just didn't feel that compelled to say to Steve at that point, we need to let them know everything.
我是说，我们谈论这件事的方式，就好像某个空房子里有六具尸体一样。这太愚蠢了。我当时并不觉得有那么大的强制力去对史蒂夫说：我们得让他们知道一切。
In the year since Jeff was released from prison, he's managed to put his life together. He got married, had a kid, landed a job teaching Public Policy at the New School in New York City. He's written a book, although he still needs a publisher.
在杰夫出狱后的一年里，他设法拼凑起自己的生活。他结婚了，有了孩子，在纽约新学院谋得了一份教公共政策的工作。他写了一本书，尽管还没找到出版商。
Steve Brown has found it a bit more difficult. He still has his wife and his children, but he can't practice law more, can't do politics, and has yet to successfully transition to a new career. It's tough to do in your mid-40s.
史蒂夫·布朗发现这稍微困难一点。他还有妻子和孩子，但他无法再担任律师，无法从政，目前还没有成功转型到新的职业。四十多岁的时候做这些很难。
They both say they've moved on from this. Neither wishes the other ill. But the two men haven't spoken since the day Jeff found out that Steve was wearing a wire. Betrayal-- it's a hard sin to forgive.
他们都说已经走出了阴影。谁也不恨谁。但自从杰夫发现史蒂夫戴着窃听器那天起，两人就再也没说过话。背叛……这是一种很难原谅的罪过。
Alex Blumberg is a producer for our show, often heard on the Planet Money podcast.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制片人，经常在《Planet Money》播客中出现。
Coming up-- the intoxicating effect of guns, spying, and the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来——枪支、间谍和《忍者神龟》的迷人效应。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Mortal versus Venial." We have stories of people trying to figure out just how bad they are. How bad is bad?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“大罪与小罪”。我们讲述了人们试图弄清楚自己到底有多“坏”的故事。坏的界限在哪里？
We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two. The Disenchanted Forest.
现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕：幻灭的森林。
So lying is a sin, right, and lying to ourselves is also wrong. But what about the lies that we all collectively believe because they make us feel better, they give us hope? How bad are those? Mortal, venial? Less than venial? Jonathan Goldstein has this story about confronting the truth.
所以说谎是罪，对吧，对自己说谎也是错的。但那些我们共同相信的谎言呢？因为它们让我们感觉更好，给了我们希望？那些有多坏？大罪，小罪？还是连小罪都算不上？乔纳森·高德斯坦带来了关于面对真相的故事。
[GAVEL POUNDING]
[木槌敲击声]
Honorable animals of the Forest Council-- Secretary Otter and Chairman Skunk-- I'm sorry, but I must interrupt. I know that time is of the essence, so I will keep my remarks brief. I stand before you not an arrogant hare, nor a flashy hare, as some of you would have it, but merely a hare who cares about this forest and all of its creatures.
尊敬的森林委员会动物们——水獭秘书和臭鼬主席——对不起，但我必须打断。我知道时间紧迫，所以我长话短说。我站在这里，不是作为一个傲慢的野兔，也不是某些人所说的那种浮夸的野兔，而仅仅是一只关心这片森林及其所有生物的野兔。
I've not coming here to cast aspersions on the tortoise. This is not a time for partisanship. Whether you be a hare man or a tortoise man, we must all work together. But to save the forest from its impending doom, it's important you know the truth about the race known as tortoise versus hare.
我来这里不是为了诋毁乌龟。现在不是党派纷争的时候。无论你是野兔派还是乌龟派，我们都必须团结一致。但为了拯救森林免于灾难，了解关于那场“龟兔赛跑”的真相很重要。
Look, I know how this makes me look. "The hare is a poor loser," you say. "The hare has a problem with tortoises." Well, I'm going to stop you right there. Let the record show that I have nothing against turtles of any kind. The snapping turtle is godfather to 27 of my kids, for crying out loud.
听着，我知道这让我看起来像什么。“野兔是个输不起的人，”你们会说。“野兔对乌龟有意见。”嗯，我要在这里打住。记录在案，我一点也不讨厌任何种类的乌龟。说真的，鳄龟还是我27个孩子的教父呢。
But if you think there is any chance that tortoise beat me fair and square, you are deluding yourselves. Tortoises don't have a reputation for being slow. They are slow. Everyone knows this. It's not a question. It's not debatable. It just is.
但如果你认为那只乌龟有任何机会公平地击败我，那你就是在自欺欺人。乌龟并没有被认为很慢。它们就是很慢。每个人都知道这一点。这不是问题，也不是争论点。事实就是这样。
So imagine my surprise when one morning, I wake up to discover the entire forest is talking about how I challenged the tortoise to a race. Think about it. Why would a hare challenge a tortoise to a race? It doesn't make any sense. What would it prove? If I win, I'm ass[BLEEP]. If I lose, I'm an embarrassment to my species.
所以想象一下当我知道整个森林都在谈论我如何挑战乌龟进行比赛时的震惊。想想看，为什么一只野兔会挑战乌龟进行比赛？这根本讲不通。这能证明什么？如果我赢了，我就是个混蛋。如果我输了，我就是物种的耻辱。
Oh, how I was vilified after that race. In the picture they ran on the cover of the Forest Post, I'm pulling my whiskers out, stomping on my top hat and yelling at a judging official. There I was, the arrogant bucktoothed hare with the fabulous libido that everyone loves to hate, finally receiving his comeuppance.
哦，那场比赛后我是如何被诋毁的。报纸封面上那张照片里，我拔着胡子，跺着大礼帽，对着裁判大吼大叫。我就在那里，那个每个人都爱恨交加、长着门牙的傲慢野兔，终于得到了报应。
And the lies that we're told about the race itself. Why would I stop just shy of the finish line and eat a large turkey dinner with all of the trimmings? Or why would I pull out a beach chair and take a suntanning break? First of all, I burn easily. And second, what am I, an idiot?
关于比赛本身，我们被告知了多少谎言。为什么我会止步于终点线前，吃一顿带有配菜的大火鸡晚餐？或者我为什么要拿出一张沙滩椅晒太阳？首先，我很容易晒伤。其次，我是什么，白痴吗？
In the days after the race, when I put forth my multiple tortoises in multiple forest nooks theory, I was labeled a paranoid, a conspiracy nut, not to mention a speceist for suggesting that tortoises all look the same. But I knew then, as I know now, that there was a network of them-- tortoises, all working in cahoots, stationed behind trees, hiding in briar patches, all along the racing route.
比赛后的几天里，当我提出“多个野兔在森林各个角落”的理论时，我被贴上了妄想狂、阴谋论者的标签，更不用说因为建议乌龟长得都一样而被视为种族歧视者。但我当时就知道，现在也知道，那是它们的一个网络——乌龟们都串通一气，站在树后，藏在荆棘丛里，沿着赛道布防。
Nonetheless, the tortoise was awarded the title of fastest in the forest, and I had no choice but to shake his wrinkled little green hand and congratulate him.
尽管如此，乌龟还是被授予了森林最快称号，我别无选择，只能握住它那皱巴巴的小绿手祝贺它。
But dear fellow forest dwellers, back to the business at hand of this emergency meeting. As Smokey Bear alerted us this morning, the forest is burning. Time is of the essence. With all due respect to the authority of this council, sending the tortoise as messenger to alert the creatures of these woods that there's a fire raging, and they must run for their lives-- not the best choice in the world. The tortoise left three hours ago, but if you rise up onto your toes, you can still see him, creeping along down there at the bottom of the hill.
但亲爱的森林居民们，回到这次紧急会议的议题上。正如烟熏熊今天早上提醒我们的，森林正在燃烧。时间就是生命。鉴于理事会的权威，派乌龟作为信使去通知林中生物火势蔓延，它们必须逃命——这绝对不是世界上最好的选择。乌龟三小时前出发了，但如果你踮起脚尖，你仍然可以看到它，在山底缓慢爬行。
So he cheated, and normally I would let this go. Who among us has not to cheated at one time or another? Possum has cheated at checkers. Fox has cheated on his taxes. And I'm the first to admit that because of my own arrogance, I've cheated myself out of your friendship. And I've also cheated with some of your wives.
所以它作弊了，通常情况下我会放过这件事。我们谁没在某个时候作弊过？负鼠在跳棋上作弊。狐狸在税收上作弊。我第一个承认，因为我自己的傲慢，我欺骗了你们的友谊。我也和你们的一些妻子偷情过。
But the point is, we can no longer let this tortoise charade go on. If we don't do something now, lives will be lost. So just give me the OK to get running, and as soon as I pick up my top hat at the blocker's, fill my jogging pipe with tobacco, eat a light dinner of sprouts and Tam Tam crackers, and get my retainer inserted, I'll be on my way.
但重点是，我们不能再让乌龟的闹剧继续下去了。如果我们现在不采取行动，生命就会流逝。所以，只要给我个信号让我跑，我一从挡路的人那里拿回大礼帽，在我的慢跑烟斗里装满烟草，吃一顿芽菜和饼干的轻晚餐，戴上护齿，我就出发。
All in favor, say aye. For the love of this forest and all that is good, please say aye.
同意的请举手。为了这片森林和所有美好的事物，请举手。
Jonathan Goldstein. His story about the tortoise and the hare is itself based on a retelling of the Aesop's fable by the 18th baron of Dunsany, Edward Plunkett. Jonathan is the host of the CBC radio show and podcast Wiretap, which you can hear on many public radio stations and you can get from the iTunes store, where a version of this story first ran.
乔纳森·高德斯坦。他关于龟兔赛跑的故事本身是基于邓萨尼男爵爱德华·庞克特对伊索寓言的重述。乔纳森是CBC电台节目和播客《Wiretap》的主持人，你可以在许多公共广播电台听到，也可以在iTunes商店获取，那个版本的这个故事就是先在那里播出的。
Act Three. The Geeks Come Out At Night.
第三幕：极客出没在夜晚。
So because the line between a mortal and a venial sin can be kind of hazy, sometimes the only way to know exactly where the line is, is just to test it. And that is particularly true when you're little. Where your parents set the line-- well, sometimes you need to figure out if you agree with your parents on where that line is. Jonathan Menjivar tells a story about a time that he tested that line.
因为大罪和小罪之间的界限可能有点模糊，有时弄清那条线在哪里的唯一方法就是去测试它。当你年纪小时更是如此。父母划定界限的地方——好吧，有时你需要弄清楚你是否同意父母对那个界限的界定。乔纳森·门吉瓦尔讲述了一个他测试界限的故事。
When I was in junior high, I spent a lot of time with this kid Tommy. That's not his real name. We went to the same school, but we ran in different circles. And then we started hanging out in Boy Scouts, and Tommy scared the hell out of me.
我在初中时和这个叫汤米的家伙混在一起。那不是他的真名。我们在同一所学校，但在不同的圈子里。后来我们在童子军中开始一起玩，汤米把我吓坏了。
I came from a strict household. Not violent strict, but come here. Take a close look at these cabinets and tell me you don't see the dust, kind of strict. So I was obedient and stuck to the rules.
我来自一个严厉的家庭。不是暴力的严厉，而是“过来。仔细看看这些柜子，告诉我你没看到灰尘”那种严厉。所以我很听话，遵守规则。
Tommy was like my real-life after school special. He did all the stupid things I knew I had to avoid if I didn't want to get in trouble, or end up hurt. We all had BMX bikes, but Tommy was the only one who would try crazy jumps. He lifted weights and got bad grades.
汤米简直就是我的现实生活中的反面教材。他做了所有我知道为了不惹麻烦或不受伤而必须避免的蠢事。我们都有BMX自行车，但汤米是唯一一个会尝试疯狂跳跃的。他举重，功课也很烂。
Tommy's house was the first place I saw porn, and a gun. We were in his parents' bedroom, and he pulled his dad's pistol out of a nightstand drawer and tried to show me how to load it. I left the room before the next scene of this very obvious plot could unfold.
汤米的家是我第一次看到色情片和枪的地方。我们在他父母卧室，他从床头抽屉里掏出他爸的手枪，试图教我怎么装弹。在剧集的下一个场景展开之前，我离开了房间。
The miracle of Tommy was that he got away with things. He didn't get caught and he didn't get hurt. At least, not that bad. When I was with him, the world seemed bigger. He was always blowing right past boundaries that I didn't even know how to approach.
汤米的奇迹在于他总能侥幸逃脱。他没被抓，也没受伤。至少，没受那么重的伤。和他在一起时，世界看起来更广阔。他总是冲过那些我甚至不知道如何靠近的边界。
One day Tommy told me he had a huge crush on a neighbor who lived across the street from him-- this married woman who was pretty in a metal video kind of way. She was blonde with that super-short haircut Demi Moore had in ghost, and Tommy said he'd seen her naked. He told me that sometimes at night, he'd get all dressed up in black clothes and sneak out of his house so he could look in her bathroom window. He said he'd seen her come out of the shower.
有一天汤米告诉我，他暗恋住在街对面的一位邻居——那个已婚女人，有一种金属视频里的那种漂亮。她留着黛米·摩尔在《人鬼情未了》里的那种超短发，汤米说他见过她裸体。他告诉我，有时在晚上，他会穿上全黑衣服溜出家门，去偷看她的浴室窗户。他说他见过她洗澡出来。
To me, the whole thing seemed more frightening than sexy. And wrong. Tommy didn't seem to have that problem.
对我来说，这一切看起来比性感更可怕。而且是错的。汤米似乎没有这种烦恼。
So Tommy came to my house for a sleepover. I think we'd stopped using that word, but that's what it was. I was used to putting on my pajamas at 6:00 and settling in for the night. Tommy showed up with a duffel bag and came into my room, clearly prepared for something else. He shut my bedroom door, opened the bag, and pulled out all these homemade weapons he'd made in his dad's garage. There were several foot-long swords made from pieces of sheet metal with little wood handles, and a weapon called a sai, like the one the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle Raphael used. God, I loved Raphael.
所以汤米来我家过夜。我想我们已经不再使用那个词了，但当时就是那样。我习惯于6点换上睡衣准备入睡。汤米带了一个帆布包进了我的房间，显然准备好了别的什么。他关上房门，打开包，掏出他在他爸车库里做的所有自制武器。有好几把一英尺长的剑，是用板金做的，带个小木柄，还有一种叫“钗”的武器，就像《忍者神龟》里的拉斐尔用的那种。天哪，我太爱拉斐尔了。
Anyhow, Tommy took all the weapons and stuffed them in between my mattress and box spring, and pretended like it was all totally normal. Which I did, too. Then we did your standard sleepover stuff-- baked some pizza or whatever-- and I fell asleep watching Saturday Night Live.
总之，汤米把所有武器塞进我的床垫和弹簧床之间，假装这一切完全正常。我也这么做了。然后我们做了标准的孩子过夜活动——烤了披萨什么的——我就看着《周六夜现场》睡着了。
A little after midnight, Tommy woke me up. He said it was time for night maneuvers. Night maneuvers was this game Tommy and a friend had made up where they'd basically taken all the things we were into-- role playing games, and Atari, and ninjas-- and they tried to make them real. They would dress up at night in black and run these little missions around the neighborhood, sneaking around and sometimes going into people's yards to see what could be seen. That was night maneuvers.
午夜过后不久，汤米叫醒了我。他说该进行“夜间演习”了。夜间演习是他和一个朋友编出来的游戏，基本上他们把所有我们痴迷的东西——角色扮演游戏、雅达利、忍者——拿出来，试图让它们变成现实。他们会打扮成黑衣人，在晚上进行这些小任务，在邻里间溜达，有时潜入人们院子里看看能发现什么。这就是夜间演习。
We snuck out my bedroom window and ran from shadow to shadow on my street, hiding behind cars and bushes so no one would spot us. We were both wearing black. Tommy was the one wearing a backpack with swords in it.
我们从卧室窗户溜出去，在街上的阴影中奔跑，躲在汽车和灌木丛后面以免被发现。我们都穿着黑色的衣服。汤米背着装剑的背包。
My heart was racing, but it wasn't actually fun. We hadn't gone far-- we were still on my street, just a few houses away-- and I was sure we'd get caught. Each time we went for it, we had to run through these big, bright spots from the streetlights, and then crouch down again. Every time I would hesitate and fumble, thinking, this is bad, this is bad, this is bad, I'm going to get caught, I'm going to get caught, I'm going to get caught-- it never got easier. But Tommy did it with grace, like this was his Olympic sport.
我的心在狂跳，但其实并不好玩。我们没走远——还在街上，离家只有几栋房子的距离——我确定我们会被抓到。每次我们冲刺时，都必须穿过路灯投下的明亮区域，然后再次蹲下。每次我犹豫和笨拙时，心里都在想：这很糟糕，这很糟糕，这很糟糕，我要被抓了，我要被抓了，我要被抓了——这从来没变得容易过。但汤米动作优雅，就像这是他的奥林匹克运动。
We went down the street, snuck around in the backyard of a friend of mine, and then jumped the fence and ended up near these railroad tracks where there weren't any streetlights. Finally, a place where no one was going to see us. We were safe.
我们沿街走，潜入我朋友的后院，然后翻过栅栏，最终到达了那些没有路灯的铁轨附近。终于，一个没人能看到我们的地方。我们安全了。
And for the first time, I felt just how incredible what we were doing really was. Here at night, letting my eyes adjust to the dark, looking up and seeing whatever little stars were there-- it was completely serene in a way I didn't know was possible. I don't think there's anything I could do right now that would give me the sense of confidence and possibility that I felt then. Being outside like that with no one to watch over me-- I thought that that's what it must feel like to be a grown-up. The air felt good in my lungs, the night wide open.
第一次，我感受到我们所做的事情真正是多么不可思议。在夜晚，让眼睛适应黑暗，抬头看着那里的星星——这有一种我不知道可能存在的完全的宁静感。我不认为我现在能做任何事能带给我当时感到的那种自信和可能性。像那样在没人看管的情况下出现在外面——我想这一定就是成为大人的感觉。空气在我的肺里感觉很好，夜晚广阔而开放。
I watched Tommy jump into a couple yards and peer through sliding glass doors. From where I stood, safe on the other side of a cinderblock wall, Tommy didn't seem to have superhuman calm or ninja moves anymore. He was just a dumbass kid, out at night, looking for things to get away with. Same as me. I thought he'd probably never even seen his neighbor naked.
我看着汤米跳进几个院子，通过推拉玻璃门向里张望。从我站在水泥墙另一边的安全位置看，汤米再也没有那种超人的冷静或忍者动作了。他只是个笨蛋小孩，在晚上出来，寻找可以侥幸逃脱的事。和我一样。我想他可能根本没见过邻居裸体。
We started heading back to my house, and then something happened that sobered me up. It separated the Tommys from the Jonathans.
我们开始往回走，然后发生了一件事让我清醒过来。它区分了“汤米”和“乔纳森”。
We got near a streetlight and decided to duck behind a car. From the driveway, we could see a man watching TV in his living room. It wasn't long before the man took his eyes off the TV and noticed us. Tommy yelled at me to run, but, you know, I'm chicken, so I just stood there while the man caught us and screamed at us, saying, whatever we'd done to his car, we were going to pay for. I was sure we were going to pay heavily.
我们靠近一盏路灯，决定躲在车后。从车道望去，可以看到一个男人在客厅看电视。没多久，那人就把视线从电视上移开注意到了我们。汤米冲我大喊快跑，但是，你知道，我是个胆小鬼，所以我只是站在那儿，直到那人抓住我们，对我们大喊大叫，说无论我们对他的车做了什么，我们都要付出代价。我确定我们要付出惨重的代价。
Then the man looked into my eyes and said the most frightening words I'd ever heard-- "I know who your parents are." He let me stew in the fear for a while, then he let us go.
然后那个人看着我的眼睛说出了我听过最可怕的话：“我知道你们父母是谁。”他让我沉浸在恐惧中一会儿，然后放我们走了。
We ran back to my house and snuck into my bedroom through the windows. It was like everything we'd just done was rewound back onto the tape, never to be heard again.
我们跑回我家，从窗户溜进我的卧室。感觉就像我们刚才做的一切都被倒带回磁带里，再也不会被听到了。
I crawled into bed and felt my heart try to escape my chest for a good half hour. Tommy fell asleep right away.
我爬进床，感觉我的心试图在胸腔里挣脱好半小时。汤米立刻睡着了。
That night was the first and last time I tried night maneuvers-- the last time I tried anything, really. I never TP'ed anyone's house. I didn't drink until I was in college. I wasn't even tempted. Was something a little bit bad, really bad? I didn't care anymore. Either way, I knew I didn't have the stomach for it. And I was totally OK with that.
那天晚上是我第一次也是最后一次尝试夜间演习——真的，最后一次尝试任何事。我再也没去别人家扔过卫生纸。直到上大学我才喝酒。我甚至没被诱惑过。是一点点坏还是真的很坏？我不在乎了。无论哪种情况，我知道我没那个胆子。而且我完全接受这一点。
Jonathan Menjivar is a producer for our program.
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔是我们节目的制片人。
[MUSIC - "UP TO NO GOOD" BY THE HARVEY SWAGGER BAND]
[音乐 - 哈维·斯瓦格乐队的《Up To No Good》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Matt Kielty. Scouting help from [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Baker, music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes.
好了，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普戴克共同制作。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康顿是办公室经理。制作协助来自马特·基尔蒂。侦察协助来自[听不清]贝克，音乐协助来自达米安·格雷夫和罗布·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can get tickets to our May 10 cinema event, coming up soon-- if you've heard about me talking about this already, ad infinitum, you know that we are doing our show onstage. We're beaming it into movie theaters everywhere. We've added David Sedaris to the all-star lineup. David Sedaris now joins Mike Birbiglia, David Rakoff, Tig Notaro, Snap Judgment's Glynn Washington and others. This, I say in all sincerity, is the most ambitious live event we've ever done, filled with things designed for you to see. Animation, dancing. Tickets are going fast. It's one night only, May 10. Find a movie theater near you at thisamericanlife.org. American
我们的网站，在那里你可以买到我们5月10日电影活动门票，很快就要来了——如果你已经听我不断提起过这件事，你就知道我们要在舞台上演出。我们正在将其转播到各处的电影院。我们增加了大卫·塞达里斯到全明星阵容中。大卫·塞达里斯现在加入了麦克·比比利亚、大卫·拉科夫、蒂格·诺塔罗、《Snap Judgment》的格林·华盛顿等人。我真诚地说，这是我们做过最雄心勃勃的现场活动，充满了专为你设计的东西。动画、舞蹈。票卖得很快。只有一晚，5月10日。在thisamericanlife.org找到离你最近的电影院。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who sees all the long hours that we put in here in the radio show, and asks me all the time--
《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他看到了我们在电台节目中付出的所有漫长工作时间，并总是问我——
What are you running away from? Why don't you just settle down and have a normal life?
你在逃避什么？为什么不找份工作过正常生活？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共电台。